when it comes to women i've as far as
game's concerned
uh one thing i've really kind of come
into
a problem is understanding the balance
between
if you were to approach some a girl or a
woman and uh you're showing intent and
attraction but how do you approach them
without coming off as needy like since
you're supposed to the
thing is i find the most success when i
just don't care
here's here's what i would recommend you
do um
as you're going about your day you go to
the bank you get your coffee you put gas
in your car you see a coo
a cute girl just chat her up that's what
i usually do
even if you don't ask her out or ask for
a number or say
hey i've enjoyed talking to you but i
gotta run i'm super busy i'd love to
continue this conversation what's your
number
right just just just chat them up and
start getting comfortable
with giving zero f's about how they how
they respond to you
you're gonna start to notice after a
while that women will give indicators of
inter
interest small ones like you have to be
able to you know pick up on the body
language how they're talking you when
they start asking you questions and
stuff like that
but you just can't care about it right
like
like when you see myron gaines talk
about the amount of approaches that he
makes like he'll make 40 approaches and
close one or two
right right but i'm sure he's
he's walking around miami just talking
to every hotty thotty that he like comes
across
so you know it's a numbers game but i
don't
like the idea of like cold approaching
like oh you know i got to get my uh
quota of uh you know 40 girls today i'd
rather
focus on chasing excellence and as i'm
going about my day if there's
you know if there's some attractive
women that are around i'm at the bank
i'm getting gas
i'm at the coffee shop just chat them up
right
and that way you don't worry about the
approach anxiety you don't really care
whether they say yes or no
you'll probably end up closing some
you're gonna get shot down by a lot too
you're gonna get the i have a boyfriend
i'm busy no piss off weirdo whatever
right
who cares you know maybe you see them
again you probably aren't going to
anyway where do you live do you live in
a big city
i live uh actually pretty close to miami
i'm on the opposite side on the gulf
side
in the naples town oh it's a nice area
so yeah okay well
it's not a huge town but i mean like
still just just just kind of do it as
you go about your day man
you